in the beginning there was nothing
even the infinity stones were but the
shadow of a dream then there was the
first sun galaxies and then a bunch of
other boring stuff and then there was
kingdom eternal extraordinaire and giant
movie star
pure of heart and big of bicep he
sorry did you
say anything
okay
thank you
bestowed with powers far beyond a mortal
man kingdom protects humanity from evil
deviance aided in his quest by a
revolving cast of sidekicks some of whom
oh
seriously dude sidekick oh god i was
just making it my own i was like
everything you make everything your own
sorry sorry assistance is that better
okay i can see that's not good helpers
what's going on oh you're gonna love
this uh-huh
i oh what'd you say was come on
angelina jolie is not one of the
sidekicks she's one of the main ones
okay all right all right i'll start over
let me just
start over okay please
[Music]
in the beginning
if you guys could not look at me it
makes me
very juicy okay we'll turn around but
she's not gonna turn around yeah just
turn around thank you